It's Emil's turn
It's my turn...
You gave it a small kick!
I don't feel like a table anymore
Okay, now I'm back
Moving table!
I won!
Okay now let's put a net onto the racket
Yea, this is how I originally thought that the challenge was meant to be
Net serve
Table is there!
The table is not over there, though!
How did I missed it?
Where is it?
It's still in play!
You were in the way!
Comment who do you think won that match
The rules are a bit unclear!
It's up to you to decide
But yea, guys go get yourself one of these!
Yea, it's very useful if you want to use a racket as a table!
Getting...
A bit tired...
Maybe...
A few more shots...
Then I've had it...
That's it
Good night
Table tennis balls?
Back to sleep...
I got a feeling this is going to be a lot harder for me than the opponent
Normal rubber (red) and long pimples (black)
Interesting
I just gotta trust it!
No!
I think that suits Emil better than me
Definitely!
It broke
What?
Just kidding
Well that was wrong!
I mean... not bad!
Look at that!
You hit it with the pimples!
Under the table!
It's just really difficult
But this is in a way interesting to try out
Because it shows where you actually hit the shots
Wrong rubber!
It would have been on!
It's about 50-50 which one you hit with
Yea... about!
No! He got it on!
What?
I gave you a spot
No but it was harder than I thought
But...
The biggest issue for me was that the rubber was too good